okay fellas there's a lot that makes the
Toy Story movies so awesome but did you
know all those toys have some serious
rules to follow stay tuned to find out
which set of rules keeps the toys a
secret from the humans in Toy Story 4
well actually not just one I have all
the questions the coast is clear
the number one rule that all toys have
to follow is pretty simple don't move or
talk when there are humans around can
you imagine what would happen if humans
saw the toys acting like they do in the
movies they would totally freak out but
sometimes we wonder how they know when
people are gone sometimes they move
around when humans are right around the
corner the door isn't even always closed
that seems pretty risky there is
probably some sort of magical ability
that lets them know the coast is clear
if there wasn't surely someone would see
them by accident we have definitely
tried to peek in on our own toys to see
if they are talking but unfortunately
they seem to be following this rule to
the T positions everyone
the other major rule that we see the
toys following is even more difficult
they are supposed to be in the same
place that the humans left them wow we
can't remember the position we slept in
last night how do these toys remember
exactly where their kid left them they
move around a lot they even go on huge
adventures but somehow they remember
exactly how they were lame maybe they
write it down to remember they never
seem to forget we wish we had that cool
ability when our mom or dad loses the
car in the parking lot don't hurt your
kid if it weren't for kids toys wouldn't
be toys they would just be things but
kids are the ones who give toys a
purpose and while all kids are special
toys are most loyal to their own kid
it's important that they never hurt
their kids feelings we can see this in
the trailers for Toy Story 4 for Q is
never meant to be a toy but he is the
most important thing to Bonnie so it's
up to all of Bonnie's toys to keep him
safe they can't let Bonnie get her
feelings hurt and losing for ki would
totally do that
animals can see them so toys can't move
when people are around if their backs
are turned they can move just a little
four people are the only ones who can
snow the truth about toys
Andy's dog is seen around the toys a lot
in the movies and that is totally ok
it might weird out animals to see toys
walking and talking
but since animals can't talk it's fine
to move around them it's a good thing
too the toys would have a way harder
time on adventures if they couldn't move
around pets hey wait a second humans
aren't the only ones with toys do you
think dog and cat toys can talk to
[Music]
together forever
this rule is pretty sad and it was
basically the whole plot of Toy Story 3
toys are not allowed to leave their
humans ok so they can go away with the
intention of coming back that's why they
are able to go after lost toys but they
can't decide not to belong to a kid I
have to go back I'm still Andy's toy
they can only leave if the kid has
forgotten them or abandoned them that's
why lotsa was a loner and that's why
Sarge takes the green army men away in
the 3rd movie they had already been
abandoned we are just glad the rest of
the toys ended up living with Bonnie
thanks Andy act natural sometimes
situations call for the first rule to be
broken the toys might need to distract a
human here's how they get around this if
the person isn't watching too closely
they can act naturally for example what
he can say his recordings the person
might think that the string got pulled
or that he is malfunctioning this
happens a few times in the movies
electronic toys like buzz can also act
like they are malfunctioning as long as
the toys don't act too suspicious they
can get away with a little talking or
movements your kid calls the shots
we know that the toys sometimes like to
play by themselves in Toy Story 3 they
have a whole Wild West scene but what
they love most is to be played with by
kids the toys in Toy Story might be
thinking individuals but they are
designed for kids to have fun and one
rule is super important for this the kid
decides how you play mr. Potato Head
might not want to be the bad guy but if
his kid makes him out to be one he has
to go along with it and if the kids are
rough with the toys oh well the kids at
the daycare are not nice to the toys but
the toys can't do anything about it
during playtime making a mess is okay
the Toy Story toys might have to hide
their identities but they can definitely
leave evidence of their existence around
there's only one covet to this role
whatever evidence they leave can't be
directly linked to the toys this means
that the toys can make a total mess they
can cause major damage but as long as no
one knows it's the toys it's totally
fine
in Toy Story 2 the toy stole a car
strangers from the outside they crashed
other cars and caused a huge mess at
Al's Toy Barn but they didn't have to
clean it up somehow
we don't think blaming the mess on our
toys will get us out of cleaning our
rooms rules are made to be broken
sometimes these rules are really hard to
follow and sometimes to observe one rule
the toys have to break another well
we're not doing that and that is totally
cool in the Toy Story world in the first
movie the toys break a lot of rules so
they can save buzz and get back to Andy
they move in front of Sid and scare him
so today nice they even stand up to Sid
so he won't torture them but the one
rule that woody was trying to follow was
to keep his kid happy he would do
anything to get all the toys back to
safety for Andy and now he's doing the
same thing for Bonnie love your kid the
most important role that all toys follow
is to love their kid they were made to
bring kids happiness and to help them
even Lotso loved his kid before he was
lost but it looks like woody is going to
have to face this rule head-on in the
new movie he would do anything to bring
forky back to Bonnie but then he is
reunited with the love of his life Bo
Peep and she shows him that Leena lost
toy can be pretty cool loving a kid
isn't as easy as woody remembers what do
you think woody will choose in Toy Story
4 let us know in the comments thanks for
watching the things give this video a
big thumbs up and hit that subscribe
button we'll catch you next time
[Music]